2026년 5월 21일 목요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 혼조세였습니다.
이란 전쟁이 외교적으로 해결되고 호르무제협이 다시 열릴 수 있다는 기대 속에
유가는 하락하고 증시는 상승했습니다.
이날 시장은 이란발 엇갈린 소식에 장 초반 크게 흔들리는 모습을 보였습니다.
이란 ISNA는 미국 측 협상안을 두고 양측의 이견이 좁혀졌다고 보도하며
기대감을 높인 반면 로이터통신은 이란 최고 지도자가
V급 농축 우라늄의 해외 반출을 금지했다고 보도하며
협상 타결 전망에 불확실성을 더했습니다.
하지만 장 시작 후 알자지라가 우라늄 관련 새로운 지시가 내려진 바 없다며
앞선 보도를 부인하자 시장 분위기는 반전되었습니다.
이어 루비오미 국무장관이 이란과의 합의 가능성에 대해 몇 가지 좋은 증후가 있다고 언급하고
파키스탄 중재단의 해외랑 방문 가능성까지 언급하고
하면서 증시는 반등했습니다.
여기에 이란 언론이 호르무제협 통행 보장과 휴전 이행을 담은
최종 합의 발표가 임박했다고 보도하면서 전쟁 종료 기대감은 더 커졌습니다.
이러한 소식에 장중 급등락을 보이던 육한은 결국 하락했습니다.
미 국채금리 역시 장중 상승분을 되돌리며 증시 반등에 힘을 보탰습니다.
이 같은 흐름 속에 바우지 수는 0.56% 상세하며
2월 이후 처음으로 사상 최고치를 기록했습니다.
다만 불씨는 여전히 남아있습니다.
이란이 호르무제협 통제권을 공식화하기 위해
오만과 영구적인 통행료 징수 제도를 논의 중인 가운데
트럼프 대통령은 호르무제협은 통행료 없이 완전히 개방돼야 한다고 강조했습니다.
나아가 미국이 결국 이란의 고농축 우라늄 비축분을 회수하게 될 것이라며
미국의 강경한 입장을 고수했습니다.
이제 시장의 방향성은 이란 전쟁에 달려있다는 평가입니다.
실적 시즌2에서
시즌이 사실상 끝나면서 추가 호재를 기다리기 어려워진 만큼
시장의 관심이 다시 이란으로 쏠렸기 때문입니다.
이런 가운데 투자자들은 경제 지표에도 집중했습니다.
지난주 신규 실업상 청구 건수는 감소하며
미국 노동시장이 여전히 견주하다는 점을 보여줬습니다.
노동시장이 버티고 있는 만큼 연준 입장에서는
경기 둔화보다 인플레이션 위험에 더 무게를 둘 여지가 커졌습니다.
미국의 제조업 활동도 4년 만에 가장 큰 폭으로 확장됐습니다.
이론은
이란 전쟁으로 공급 차질과 가격 상승 우려가 커지자
기업들이 선제적으로 재고 확보에 나선 영향입니다.
실적 발표도 함께 소화했습니다.
전쟁의 기업에 미치는 영향을 보여주는 최신 사례로
월마트는 연료비 상승이 자사의 수익성을 압박하고 있으며
소비자 가격 인상으로 이어질 수 있다고 경고했습니다.
한편 엔비디아는 시장의 높은 기대치에 부합하는
분기 실적과 전망을 내놨음에도 소폭 하락했습니다.
애널리스트들은 대체로 긍정적인 시각을 유지했지만
경쟁이 심화되고 섹터 밸류션에 대한 투자자들의 의심이 커진 가운데
엔비디아의 성장세가 얼마나 지속될 수 있을지에 대해서는
일부 의문을 제기했습니다.
글래메드의 제이슨 프라이드는
실적 발표 시즌이 마무리되면서 증시를 이끌던 상승 동력이 줄어들었고
이에 따라 시장의 시선이 지적적 이슈로 옮겨가고 있다.
더 웰스 얼라이언스의 로버트 콘조는
엔비디아에 대한 투자자들의 눈높이가 너무 높아지면서
시장 기대치를 맞추기가 점점 어려워지고 있다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 22일 금요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는